un animal trop affectueux un court reçu
une baignoire qui vous tombe sur la tête
avec ses affiches humoristiques la
caisse d'assurance maladie des Yvelines
lance une vaste campagne de
communication sur le recours
qu'entretien derrière cette formulation
complexe un constat simple bon nombre
d'accidents sont causés par une tierce
personne un accident de la route une
bousculade à l'école une morsure
d'animaux même si l'accident n'est pas
volontaire les soins devraient être
prises en charge par l'assurance du
responsable finalement la curé pourrait
dire ça change pas grand chose pour moi
pour moi dans les deux cas me faire
rembourser la seule chose c'est que
c'est l'argent public et il n'y a pas de
raison que ce soit sur l'argent public
que on paye ses soins alors que
normalement ça serait une compagnie
d'assurance ou un tiers qui devrait le
payer
l'enjeu est de taille en 2013
l'assurance maladie des Yvelines a pu
récupérer 18 millions d'euros au niveau
national le montant s'élève à un
milliard et l'on estime que seul un
tiers des cas sont déclarés en 2013 près
de 5000 accidents ont été officiellement
causés par un tiers responsable à 60%
des cas des accidents de la route car un
protocole facilite les échanges avec les
assurances
pour déclarer un cas trois options sont
possibles par mail sur le site ameli.fr
parcouriez ou par téléphone au 36 46 des
partenariats sont également mis en place
avec les instances médicales et les
forces de l'ordre
travailler avec beaucoup
d'établissements du département parce
que les acteurs ont changé il faut
remobiliser à chaque fois pour qu'il
soit bien
conscient de l'importance et qui nous
avertit le plus rapidement possible des
affiches devraient être distribuées en
septembre dans les établissements
scolaires pour rappeler qu'être
responsable ne signifie pas être
coupable